mon espace bière vous connaissez c'est
le présentateur des jeux de 20 heures
c'est aussi l'animateur des petit matin
sur rtl
et depuis peu c'est la vedette d'un
ouvrage paru aux presses de la cité
matin pas chagrin pour cet ouvrage
michel leblanc vous a prêté sa main
droite et son stylo ça ma droite et
saura-t-il et oui oui et c'est un peu
bizarre parce que durant tout cet
ouvrage vous expliquer qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire pour les téléspectateurs ou
pour les auditeurs de connaître un peu
la vie privée des animateurs d'un autre
côté vous vous livrer totalement 1 je
peux raconter ma vie privée j'ai un
petit peu expliqué qu' on arrive à
l'animation radio au théâtre la comédie
par le plus grand des hasards parce que
honnêtement rien ne me prédestinait à
faire ce métier du tout puisque je suis
leur dos j'allais enfin d'une famille
très simple j'aurais pu être comme le
dit michel qui est derrière moi et c'est
pour ça que je me suis retourné à bondy
géomètre coureurs cyclistes ou les
petits métiers que j'ai fait avant
évidemment et or dans ce bouquin de vue
évidemment on a voulu expliquer que rien
n'était impossible mais finalement quand
on peut partir de d'un tout petit pays
et puis arrivé à sur les antennes d'une
semaine tous les téléspectateurs et sur
les téléviseurs par la même occasion
et puis c'est surtout suivez le guide un
peu ce bouquin dans le dans les métiers
de théâtre que j'ai fait dans les
métiers de cinéma dans le métier de
présentateur radio reporters
photographes etc
suivez le guide et voyez un petit peu
les petites histoires qui ont pu
m'arriver mai soit histoires des autres
que j'ai vu et que je raconte
d'accord tout le monde est d'accord vous
êtes un personnage c'est jovial jour de
prière et on apprend
vous avez en fin de compte un très
mauvais caractère j'ai un si mauvais
caractère riche coléreux bonsoir cela
n'empêche pas le jeu via lite est ce que
je me mets en colère je crée et puis
après je suis embêté alors je viens je
vais m'excuser gentiment michel leblanc
comment s'est passée cette collaboration
avec maurice favières en voit très bien
puisque c'est moi qui ai tout fait
oui voilà le maté oui un petit peu dans
la vérité c'est que c'est parti comme ça
d'une discussion un jour c'est un repas
dans un restaurant maurice m'a dit qu'il
allait faire ça je dis ça m'amuse on a
travaillé tous les deux on a d'abord
fait des enregistrements pendant les
week-ends et les vacances à peu près 70
heures sur cassette
j'ai des pouilles et tout ça je me suis
enfermé j'ai écrit les quelques pages
qui sont là ensuite je lui ai demandé ce
que tu es d'accord j'ai quand même fait
lire pour qu'ils soient d'accord et se
croient que pour finir connaissant le
risque comme je le connaissais je crois
que si j'ai pu le faire c'est parce
qu'on se connaît depuis plus de 20 ans
et je crois que c'est pour ça que j'ai
pu le faire c'est à dire de suivre
exactement ce qu'il a voulu dire au
travers de sa vie c'est pas du tout
l'avis de quelqu'un qui part depuis le
premier jour de la naissance jusqu'à
maintenant sur les écrans de télé comme
il le dit c'est à dire que c'est
effectivement au cours de deux séances
de théâtre en cours de film de cinéma
pour deux studios de passage dans les
studios de télévision ou dans les
studios de radio que il se passe quelque
chose on rencontre quelqu'un et à sion
la salle on revient sur sa propre
expérience et sur les autres personnes
qu'il a rencontrées dans sa vie je crois
que c'est comme ça que ça m'amuse et je
les fais un journaliste d'accord durant
la gestation de cet ouvrage devient
rester une anecdote un petit moment de
franche rigolade non pas dans le livre
non il ya au moins une chose c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'il disait tout à
l'heure il ne m'a jamais tapé dessus
enfin du moins pas encore quoi donc à
mon avis ça va être content de sa
collaboration
la sienne oui il est content d'ailleurs
on en prépare un autre c'est le blanc vu
parfait bière et là vous allez prêter au
jeu du portrait ma main gauche et mon
crayon puisque je vais pas les murs déjà
ce sera le mot de la fin